freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
heute mit einem ganz ganz besonderen
gast meiner schwester wird er warte auf
meinen kanal schon mal zu sehen noch nie
wir haben video machte das ging auch
call durch die decke das hat über eine
million aufrufe dadurch einen tag lang
gemacht was verrät heute heute würde ich
das nicht mehr machen wir heute wird sie
bestimmt viel mehr sachen als damals
heute drehen wir mal wieder zusammen ein
persönlicher koch und tabea hat sich zum
frühstück sehr gut weil soufflé pancakes
gewünscht letzte ausgabe des tk sondern
wir diese fred hendricks auch sich
relativ einfach in der macht aber man
muss sehr vorsichtig sein
deshalb volle konzentration ist ein
bisschen was vorbereitet das sind 60
gramm mehl bisschen meine letzte
bisschen backpulver milchzucker damit
ihr müsst mir unser einschlagen vier
eier auch wenn man schlau bist dann
immer nicht so eine schüssel wie ich
gerade benutzen sondern richtige bank
schlechter aber meine einzige tag im
hintergrund und da bereitet schon das
abendessen sind vor könnt ihr mal raten
was es ist ein bisschen was machen fünf
weil ich so klein sind wenn ihr normal
groß sagt macht aber einfach vier so
dann nehmen wir das eigelb wie ich es
einmal an
dazu fügen jetzt 30 gramm mich es ist
sehr wenig ich weiß aber es muss sein
okay dann nehmen wir unsere mischung aus
sechs gramm backpulver ein bisschen
vanille zucker bisschen salz und 60
gramm mehl untersieben
das ganze hier hinein verbinden wir das
ganze habe ich sehr stört tatsächliche
schüssel hat und das nicht mit einem
tiefen teller haben
jetzt schnappen wir uns einen
schneebesen und schlagen das 1
dann gehen wir unseren zucker ist sehr
gut etwa ein viertel kommt unsere
mischung finden das dem ganzen hin zu
entheben dass wir zu langsam drunter und
werde jetzt aber den rest wahl und
möchten den organisation sehr gut dass
wir hier verlieren kannst du uns helfen
und das hier offen halten dass unsere
mischung
ich hab schon ein bisschen angst dass es
vielleicht so flüssig ist unsere fahrer
ist auf niedriger hitze vorgeheizt dies
trotzdem sehr heiß also auf jeden fall
die zeit geben die sie braucht und
vorhalten und jetzt machen wir zwei
häufchen aus dem teil
jetzt gehen wir einfach einen esslöffel
wasser haben die stellen wo kein fan
gucken ist und schließen das ganze für
fünf minuten
fünf minuten sind vergangen das ganz
normal sehr gut wir haben schon eine
gute höhe
jetzt nehmen wir uns wieder unsere
mischung und machen eine zweite lage um
drauf es sieht soweit ganz gut aus würde
ich sagen das war auch sehr gut haben
wir dazu weitere vier minuten
dort hat gesehen wie die dinger aussehen
natürlich sehr zufrieden damit wurde sie
jetzt mal raus
sie sehen auf jeden fall nicht besonders
gut aus aber ich probiere sie noch ein
bisschen schön zu dekorieren
es ist soweit herbert eine erste
mahlzeit ich muss sagen das haben wir
per märz gekippt
ich finde aber sie sehen jetzt
angerichtet gar nicht mehr so super
schlecht aus werden nimmt gerne die
erste gabe das ganze mit karamellsoße
und frischen beeren getoppt ok dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns gleich
wieder wenn du auch gegessen hast du so
sieht seinen pancake übrigens aus wenn
er nicht verkauft ist aber die fahne war
einfach zu voll mit den beiden so tobias
komplett aufgegessen der terrorist
wirklich leer gefegt sieht schonmal gut
aus wie würdest du das frühstück
bewerten also vom text her muss man
seine klare ziel von 10 kann die kantig
kritisieren zwar auch sehr sättigend und
jetzt sehr gut vom aussehen also jetzt
nur vom pancake rheiner band joe mazzone
sieben von zehn beim letzten war es auch
sehr gut da war es sonne 19 und von der
präsentation her auch nur zehn von zehn
zügen gebe ich insgesamt eine 59
okay okay wir haben so mittagessen ist
wird meine berühmten bürger geben der
die noch nie gegessen nur mache ich dazu
damit etwas neues gibt sachen preis also
in kartoffeln im backofen die aber
trotzdem super christian wir fangen an
mit kartoffel schälen
ich hätte so einen sack gekauft sagen
wir nehmen mal die größten raus leider
konnte man nicht irgendwie nur große
taufen oder so aber die benutze ich
einfach für
kartoffeln sind geschält jetzt form der
80 gramm welchen hackfleisch denn ihr
wisst ja dass messen müssen erst mal
platt gedrückt werden und dafür müssen
es in kügelchen sagen also davon machen
wir jetzt zwölf stück zur wirtschaft auf
dem wasser aufgesetzt wird kochen da ich
nämlich die kartoffeln bzw die pommes
erst mal vor aber dafür müssen wir
erstmal schneidet also beschneiden
sondern eineinhalb zentimeter dicke
scheiben
es wäre auf jeden fall leichter gewesen
hätte ich noch größere kartoffeln
bekommen aber so fasst das auf jeden
fall ich mache einfach dann mit den
großen kartoffeln nur eine portion für
dich kw und die schweiz auch der länge
nach auf man mal so in eineinhalb
zentimeter dicke streifen fest
anzukommen ich habe schon die seiten
dazu kommt jetzt noch damit die
kartoffel nicht zu rechnen
ein kleiner schuss essig sondern für
einen esslöffel das ändert an geschmack
gar nichts aber das verringert das
pektin abgebaut wird und besser
zerbrechen wie kommen die kartoffeln
entspricht 8 minuten lange vor als wenn
die fertig sind kommen sie den ofen wir
schütten die kartoffeln 8 das ist ein
kurs 12 minuten den wasserdampf ab wir
gehen jetzt die pommes hinein sind die
aber sie brechen auseinander sehr gut
ist geben wir dazu ein bisschen höhe und
sondern will und drehen jetzt vorsichtig
in dem höhe also auf jeden fall
großzügig weiß nicht wie viel das in
gramm oder milliliter sind vielleicht 50
meter haben wenn das erledigt ist das
nehmen wir unseren berufen und geben sie
drauf möglichkeiten sich einen früheren
und es geht jetzt erst 15 und 15 minuten
sind vorbei
nicht wenn du jetzt mal die kartoffel
erzählt sie uns wirklich ganz gut es ist
ordentlich daran alle kartoffeln bandit
ausgegeben die wieder ein tipp weitere
15 minuten und wir schütten jetzt das öl
ab was noch da war überfällig ist
sondern geben wir jetzt 13 letter zähler
in die schüssel hineinschütten die form
ist da rüber und küssten sie direkt ein
bisschen oben seid und hin und her
flitzen bisschen paprika und lasst uns
kurz abkühlen aber leute so denken ist
sehr gut vorgeheizt fast 300 grad
geöffnet und gehen so fleischbällchen
drauf drücken
das sind wir immer 80 gramm pro partie
sehr schöne rollen und wirklich komplett
können ist heute dadurch zum tanzen und
dann nehmen wir die bank darunter mario
für mich meinte niersbach
wer mag es nicht so gern scharf grill
aus und wir machen die kommission die
state of price hat er sich gewöhnt
[Musik]
okay das ist endlich soweit muss das
lange warten ein paar mit einem vom ist
wenn wir noch einen kleinen besucher an
der seite aber macht gerne mal den
crunch hessen ist es und dann darfst du
wie gewohnt ganze nur aufpassen dass wir
das hier aus dem ofen kommen so kann der
blick scheint was gut ist super sprechen
ja auch selber zeugmann meint burger wir
sehen uns gleich zu bewerten so die
letzten pur gegessen werden teller leer
geputzt das ist schon mal sehr gut also
beim frühstück und mittagessen wurde
komplett aufgerissen habe kommen wir zu
einer bewertung muss sich vielleicht
viele überraschend wird ich warte sich
mit über 1200 pommes als vom bürger
nicht weil der bürger nicht gut war
sondern weil die post so gestört war und
vor allem jetzt erst mal gemacht wie man
aus dem conti in die software fochten
kommt indem man sie verkauft also ich
hab dir erst acht minuten im wasser
gekocht dementsprechend macht es zu
hause was sagst du zu bürgern darf sehr
gut
das hat alles perfekt zusammenpasst die
soße salat fertige fehlt satellit okay
das ist halt von meiner philosophie
minimalismus dreckiger käse ketchup mayo
fleisch das war's mehr kommen nicht dazu
wenn diese art klar aber für mich ist
das american schießt er werde keinen
salat von 10
10,5 prozent alles klar dass die
sehkraft und verzieht eine sehr gute
öffentlich wollte unbedingt die bürger
aber der eigentlich sah man jetzt schon
mal die commons wir sehen uns beim
abendessen wieder auch da wird es wieder
sehr komfort und willkommen zum
abendessen wir machen haben pizza ihr
seht schon alles ist vorbereitet ich
werde euch ausnahmsweise nicht zeigen
dies geht dann am mittwoch kommt ein
video wo ich mit luca zusammen meine
pizza ofen meinen neuen eingeweiht habe
da haben wir dabei rein schauen wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie ich diese pizza macht
jesus auf jeden fall meine wäldchen ich
habe für vier verschiedene pizzen unter
bhc tatsächlich ich weiß jetzt geht die
diskussion los in den kommentaren eine
pizza hawaii von mir gewünscht dass
heißt legen wir los wir schneiden
zunächst diana last haben eine frische
und eingelegte annas gekauft die frische
ananas ist leider zu dieser jahreszeit
nicht wirklich sehr frisch deshalb muss
ich hier mit der gleichen anders
arbeiten wir nehmen hier mal eine
scheibe raus glaube tatsächlich dadurch
dass die so eingelegt ist kann man ein
bisschen der hohen hitze beim backen
entgegenwirken
da bauen wir vielleicht nur noch
schinken den schneide ich auch fein
hier haben wir alle zutaten wie gesagt
ich gehe hier nicht in diesem video zu
sehen ins detail weil ihr müsst
natürlich auch noch das andere video
gucken
[Musik]
die pizza ist fertig wie gesagt wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie alles funktioniert
müsst ihr das video am mittwoch aber wir
gehen jetzt aus dem ofen und schieben
die rein also der ofen ist heiß und das
leiden ist es geht direkt los und fertig
unglaublich geiles gerät darüber kommt
jetzt noch in brüssel olivenöl und eine
prise so es ist super spät ist schon
nach 10 uhr aber das ist dein abendessen
da wäre ein selbst gebackene pizza
hawaii du hast heute wirklich glaube ich
den traum von jedem eigentlich gelebt
pancakes burger tom besitzer so ein
video macht dann ist das auch okay dann
darf man sich auch mal solche sachen
wünschen
ich bin sehr gespannt auf die zu meiner
pizza sein wirst klappt ihm ein stück
gibt dem ganzen test so du bist auch
beobachtet ich hoffe viele menschen sind
so bewerten
der letzte wissen von der pizza wird
gegessen ich sage die ganze zeit dass
wir so ein geschoss sie einzuschüchtern
für die bewertung die jetzt ansteht will
erst mal dein fazit ein tag dann gekocht
worden von großen oder alles was du
wolltest würdest du das öfter machen
wollen viel kraft dass man auf jeden
fall sehr emotional dieser aussage was
sagst du skala von 1 bis 10 zum letzten
mal was war diese pc ich hätte es mir
einfach einfach nice gemacht lecker
lecker
das ist von mir eine 10 10 mit einem
hamburger zumal zu senden
also quasi in der 95 okay es ist eine
9,5 und sie haben einen gesamtscore von
29 leute die was sehr du hast sehr gütig
zu mir in deiner bewertung ich fand es
aber auch ultra lecker was wir heute
gemacht haben also noch sehr gute
auswahl die du getroffen hast würde
sagen wir sehen uns nächsten sonntag
spiels geht nein wir sehen es mittwoch
wie man das video zum pizzabacken schaut
bist du ein mann bist du nicht
[Musik]